はいはいお前用ウッド住んでこれ
はい
その通りでございますね良い子れフェアろっぺ
1か月半の動画休んでな店だ
a
僕ですかええまあとりあえずは
まあ僕がいろいろ
問題起こすたので
完成してました反省と東ずにですねあー反省してたんですけれども
まぁ今まで動画を続けてきて
僕の中でいろんなものが溜まっておりまして
ああ
掃除機いうとああ
燃え尽きてしまいました燃え尽きちゃってなんか顔動画を撮る気もなかったし
まあいろいろ僕が問題起こしたので
1回
落ち着いて頭を冷やそうと思って
この1カ月半は
ネットから
youtube から離れて生活していますとありがたい言います
三平てはいそうですだーっ
だ全て忘れてたわけでそこか
ネットからも youtube からツイッターからを離れて何にもとらわれずに
何て言えばいいんでしょ泣いてないですなーんと
ベアー
ん7いろんなことだったんですけれどもこの休み中はあ
今までおやすみってものがなかったので1日大
今夏以降しっかり休めて
結構リフレッシュできたと思っていますもうやめないんだった正直っていうか正直へ
何をとっていいかわかりませんん
何をとっていいかわかんないんですけど
動画を撮りたくて戻ってきました
まぁ今回の件でですね大勢の人を傷つけ
大勢の人お話しません大勢の人を
失望させたと思っております僕は
こんな僕でも待っててくれた皆さん
僕の動画を楽しみしてください
liar
今わかるだろなんだよ
結構緊張してますありがとうございますこんな僕でもまた動画を待ってくれてる人が
いるのでそれでも待ってくださる皆さんのために
僕は動画を出したいと思いました
一歩パツイッター見てませんでしたアプリ9してました
ちょっとんですね
こっそり見てたけどねはい
まあいろいろ理由があったんでしょえっだけなので
色々言われるわけじゃないですか
ああああああ
仕方ないんですけども僕そういうコメントに一切反応しないんでしょ
でそれが僕だったらいいんですよ僕にいるの批判されるのも仕方ないことなんでそれは
いいんですけどもうっ
もう逆に反応しないと気づいたってみんなーアティレましたっっ
僕がするしていると何が起きるかといいますと僕をないいうと反応しないじゃないです
か
となると僕の州庁舎さんに家版とか攻撃強化し始めるんですよ
でき旭興僕の視聴者さんが批判されてその視聴者さん達も負けずとこう言い返しちゃっ
てこう
戦いみたいなのが起きててもうそうなっちゃうとこうじゃない加工
分かります
ああこうなっちゃってて批判に批判の繰り返しでもう
ブーブー思って僕はネットから姿を消しておりました
[音楽]
ブーブー
一つ言いたいことがありましてあの
本当に今応援してくれる人たちを傷つけたくないんですよ
でも多分これからもそういった批判的なことは
あり続けると思うしこれからも居続けるといると思うから
僕の主張者さんの皆さんはできれば批判を批判しないでほしいです
見せしてほしい結局に2人達って好反応を楽しいだけなんでみんなが傷つく必要はない
んで出来ればスルーして欲しいなって思ってます
はい
言えます実はそうなんですなーん
そして
この救出に僕
考えていたことが一つだけありますはい
今後のことそんな中たはあああ
正直言いまして割と一人でやっていく自信がありません
うまく言えないんですけど
本当はもっと元気に復活したかったんですよ
復活しましたこれからも頑張りますみたいな感じでてようと思ったんですけど正直そう
いうテンションでもないんで今結構今回の件で影響力がでかすぎるということを分かっ
たんですようーで今更ですじゃあねええ
調べ車
手ぶれからんだなんでこう
軽い気持ちで今までやってて
youtube って遊びだと思ってたんですよ
今回の件で色々僕も反省したことがあったので
僕は
バカなのでああ
方なのでいろいろ考えなきゃいけないなと思って
今後のことを色々考えておりましたいやー
ありがとうございました
はい頑張ります
した方
待ってくださった皆様
大変お待たせいたしましたそして
待ってくれてありがとうございました松がいなく
賛否両論あると思いますが僕は自分のしたいことをしますそして
応援してくださる皆様に
感謝して
皆さんを大切にして
これからも動画を頑張っていきたいと思っております約1カ月半
お休みをいただいて
落ち着いて
自分自身と向き合って
いろんなことを考えて今後二度と同じような過ちは繰り返さないように
youtube
頑張って行きたいと思いますので
これからも始め冊をよろしくお願い致します
い
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ